donc comment je fais je me mets à
l'extrémité de la lettre comme ça
et je tape doucement jusqu'à arriver au
milieu
utilisez un ciseau une massette pour
graver des mots une dizaine de jeunes
d'aulnay sous bois puis s'initier à la
sculpture en taille de pierre comme
professeur un artiste de leur ville quoi
mène pour cet atelier proposé par le
fonds de dotation verrecchia au château
de là mais à versailles c'est surtout
démontrer à ses enfants qu'il ya une
possibilité d'incarner ces métiers du
patrimoine immatériel leur donner envie
pourquoi pas susciter des vocations pour
moi l'idée c'est de nous pouvons
ordonner ce que moi j'ai pas eu étant
plus jeune parce que justement on avait
pas de structure et on a toujours
l'impression que l'art c'est quelque
chose d'exclusif et moi justement je
veux donner ce message ou c'est inclusif
et est spécialement pour les jeunes sud
pour livre écrire dans l'app ce jour là
les jeunes travail sur le langage et
l'écriture ils ont dû choisir un mot a
gravé sur la pierre déjà je vous laisse
un peu de temps pour réfléchir un mot
pas n'importe quels mots je vous
choisissez un mot qui représente
vraiment d'où vous venez et votre
culture dis moi que tu as choisie
j'aime bien le judo est un sport
conquis cap vers lui mais c'est facile
comme quartier
quartier aussi parce que j'habite dans
un quartier aussi
j'aime bien le quartier pour ça j'ai
choisi ce mot foot
parce que région bien foot alors quand
je représente le moyen âge et à
plusieurs trucs dans le moyen-age la
guerre et les conflits ces communes
puis vient le temps d'enfiler son
tablier pour se mettre au travail et
réaliser la gravure sur pierre les
participants sont concentrés les gestes
appliquée et pour une première le
résultat est plus que prometteur
sauf que c'est très bien d'apprendre à
sculpter la roma sculpter des mots
des lettres
s'en sortent bien et surtout ils sont
très créatifs et c'est ce que je leur
disais juste avant c'est que défend tant
qu'artiste on cherche à puiser dans
notre notre jeunesse et lorsqu'on les
voit travailler en fait ils sont
tellement spontanée ils ont tellement
d'idées et c'est toujours beau à voir un
atelier dans le cadre de l'installation
temporaire du fonds de dotation
verrecchia au château de là mais tout
l'été aux artistes en résidence sont
succédé sur place